das war wirklich zumindest ein i3 nachbau für windows ausprobieren sagt zumindest die github
seite ob das taugt ich hab da ja so ein bisschen meine zweifel ehrlich gesagt aber wir werden sehen
erst mal package update machen wobei wir brauchen die linux vm gar nicht egal package update arch
bei der way package update kann man nicht genug machen neue version glaube ich muss die musik wie
sie leise machen sack excel wird sie nicht ein jetzt kann man das auch wieder eins hoch machen
wollte gerade sagen wir müssen so kacke eingestellt die einstellung zacken heute mal messe so also
was brauchen wir dafür
wir brauchen windows vm ich bin mir nicht sicher ob wir noch eine haben fürchte nicht den krempel
kann ich auch mal löschen oder mit proxmox cluster den brauchen wir doch niemals wieder ich weiß gar
nicht warum ich den überhaupt noch drauf haben haben services unter linux root nicht zwangsläufig
ne kommt auf den service an init hat root potenziell aber die services selbst nicht unbedingt kannst
einstellen mit welchem user die gestartet
werden soll und am besten lässt du die natürlich wenn es nicht sein muss nicht als root laufen und
wenn es sein muss kannst du als gut starten und dann privileges droppen ja korrekt wieso kein
service das funktioniert theoretisch auch man könnte man könnte ein man braucht kein service
im ziel start up script oder so könnte einen start up script bauen
das update wenn man das will ja doch das würde funktionieren aber will ich nicht weil ich will ja
sehen was er macht passwort liegt hier kommt nicht drauf was mein passwort ist ist nicht erratbar was
ist die drei das hier das was ich gerade unter den luxe 3 1 1 teiling window manager und da habe ich
letztens was gefunden auf schritt hab und zwar
wollte ich das heute mal mit euch aus das da das wollte ich heute mal ausprobieren guck mal das ist
ein i3 nachbau für windows und ich bin echt gespannt ob das so gut funktioniert wie es da aussieht ich
ich habe meine zweifel ich habe wirklich meine zweifel ob das gescheit funktioniert aber lassen
wir mal gucken nachdem ich natürlich nicht mein ja mein mein host hier betriebssystem damit versauen will
warum erstelle ich die windows vm ist ja kein ding dauert eine viertelstunde ist das ding da warum ist das illegal service
unguleich startup skript das sind analoge begriffen ne nicht unbedingt ein service ist für mich früher
was unter init beziehungsweise jetzt halt als unit file für systemd und du kannst entweder
mit systemd einzelne skripts aufrufen zum beispiel gibt es ja immer noch einen hook für wie hieß das früher etc rc local
glaube ich oder du lässt ins skript laufen wenn du dich einloggen oder wenn
dein window manager startet oder wann auch immer du willst ja aber start up
skript und service ist nicht zwangsläufig das gleiche
sowas darf es nicht gehen warum mit welchem framework sollte man heute und
das ist eine sehr gute frage da werde ich gleich was zu sagen
nachdem ich mich zum 50 mal vertippt hat bei 1 2 3 4 5 6 wie auch immer man
da schafft jetzt noch mal rebooten in der hoffnung ist alles updated so also
mit welchem framework sollte man heutzutage eine app für windows ok es
muss wenn also windows also du willst auf gar keinen fall cross-plattform
richtig wenn das schreiben wenn es keine progressive web apps sein soll
windows forms zu alt und wp tot wenn die ui3
zu jung und kinky dort maui der tonne hier du hast du hast das problem von
windows ui gut zusammengefasst man denkt echt microsoft leckt kritiker
information also wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist ein best bett
trotzdem wenn ui3 weil maui willst du dir nicht geben und wpf ist auch
ziemlich outdated
was man in vielen stellen merkt
wie so zum beispiel daran wenn du versuchst neue fonds zu verwenden oder
kalle im oder irgendwas dann geht das so ohne weiteres nicht in wpf also
wahrscheinlich ist das besser was du mal kannst doch tatsächlich eine ja wie
heißt das an package heißt es an package wenn ui3 app alternativ du kannst
natürlich auch eines der anderen kurs plattform ui technologien verwenden und
es einfach nicht crosstalken
Plattform machen. Das geht natürlich auch.
Du kannst natürlich, wenn du auf C++
stehst, sowas wie Qt
verwenden. Was finde ich zumindest,
wenn man, also der erträglichste
Part ist. Qt ist erträglich,
C++ nicht. Du kannst
auch, wenn es ein bisschen was moderneres
sein darf und du keine tiefgreifende
Betriebssystem-Integration
brauchst, sowas wie Flutter auf dem Desktop
verwenden. Wobei ich, naja, ganz ehrlich,
Flutter, ich weiß nicht. Oder
du machst, was alle
machen, die ein bisschen
abgefuckt
sind von Microsoft und UI und
C Sharp verwenden wollen, nehmen
Avalonia. Probier mal
Avalonia aus. Das ist
quasi Cross-Plattform-WPF.
Die bieten, glaube ich, mittlerweile
sogar ein Paid-Produkt an.
Boshi, danke für den Sub.
Die bieten mittlerweile, glaube ich, gerade sogar
ein Paid-Produkt an,
wo man WPF-Anwendungen
konvertieren kann in
Cross-Plattform-Anwendungen.
Wie gesagt, guck dir
Avalonia an. Also wenn du
auf diese
WPF-UWP
WinUI-Style
GUI-Sache stehst,
dann ist
Avalonia wahrscheinlich das Beste,
was du machen kannst. Ich persönlich
muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich mag diese
XML-Geschichte nicht so sehr,
was das
angeht. Wenn ich irgendwas
Kleines mache, ist es meistens,
wenn du...
Windows Forms.
Aber wenn es Windows sein muss,
weil das schön schnell geht, sieht halt hässlich
wie die Nacht aus.
Avalonia taugt.
Du kannst natürlich
auch Elektron oder sowas machen, wobei,
ich weiß ja nicht, wenn du willst,
dass dein Hello World 450 MB RAM
verbraucht. Wie gesagt,
Microsoft und UI, die kriegen es
nicht geschissen, die letzten 15 Jahre
schon nicht mehr. Von wann ist WPF?
WPF war der letzte
sinnvolle, gute Versuch von Microsoft.
Das ist kein G-Bait.
Ist kein G-Bait. Guck.
Wir probieren heute das hier aus.
Schau mal. I3 für Windows.
Oder zumindest ein I3-Nachbau
für Windows.
Keiner cross-compiled für Windows.
Geht Discord aktuell.
Also vor einer Viertelstunde ging es noch.
Boshi, danke für den
Sub. Hast du in deinem
Vorstellungsgespräch erzählt, dass du Arch-Linux-User
bist? Also ich hatte ja,
als ich wechseln wollte,
ich hatte ja insgesamt
2,5.
Vorstellungsgespräche. Das eine zählt nicht wirklich.
Das eine in Würzburg und das andere in Frankfurt.
Und ich glaube, bei dem
Vorstellungsgespräch in Würzburg,
da habe ich das, glaube ich,
tatsächlich erzählt.
Weil da hatte ich so ein Treffen mit dem Team
und da waren die Leute dabei, die dort arbeiten
und da hatten wir es auch von, welche
Distribution mag man? Und da habe ich natürlich
den Arch-By-The-Way-Witz gebracht.
Ich glaube, hier in Frankfurt
im Vorstellungsgespräch
habe ich es nicht erzählt, weil
da war einer vom
Personal.
Der hätte damit nichts anfangen können.
Und mein Chef, da war ich mir
da nicht sicher, ob er damit was anfangen könnte.
Deswegen habe ich da keinen Arch-Linux-Witz
drüber gemacht.
Frage an Chat und Streamer. Ich habe einen
neuen Laptop. Ubuntu erstmal drauf
und zählt. Bekomme in unregelmäßem Abstand
einen Blackscreen für eine Sekunde wie Trace.
Oh!
X oder Wayland? Da geht es schon los.
Das Ja des Linux-Desktops ist hier.
Wahrscheinlich Wayland.
Im Zweifelsfall Wayland,
wenn du Blackscreens kriegst.
Haha. Siehste?
Wusste ich doch. Wusste ich doch, dass du
Wayland verwenden willst.
Tja.
Gute Frage. Nächste Frage. Keine Ahnung.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ja, ich sehe es auch so,
dass Wayland wahrscheinlich die Zukunft ist,
weil niemand an X weiterbaut.
Aber
so viel Shit drinne noch,
man. Und die kriegen seit
Jahrzehnten auch schon nicht geschitzt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, dass Wayland super
neu ist. Könnt ihr euch
auch dran erinnern, woher das ist?
Wo wir das erste Mal ausprobiert haben
vor ein paar Jahren. Und ich dachte,
Moment, ist das im Stream?
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das muss ich gucken.
Jetzt muss ich gucken, ob das im Archiv ist.
Es kann sein,
dass es das noch nicht gab.
Hier, Wayland.
WM.
Guck mal, da haben wir sogar
haben wir sogar noch einen Clip.
Weiß ich.
Also, da hat es schon wieder...
So, und zumindest in diesem
Stream, da haben wir sogar noch einen Clip.
Und in diesem Stream, wo wir das
ausprobiert haben, war...
Ich kann's...
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht...
Ich glaube, den Stream haben wir gar nicht.
Doch, hier ist doch...
So, und das war
2017.
Das ist fünf Jahre her.
Und da wurde auch schon erzählt, Wayland,
Beste und so. Und da gab es das Problem,
dass
Fenster
nicht re-gesized sind.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich
das finde.
Ich finde jetzt. Aber das sind Fenster
einfach nicht re-gesized. Das sind so
Dinge, wo ich mir denke, Alter, das ist ja wirklich so
die Basics der Basics funktionierten
damals einfach nicht.
Fenster haben... Also, wenn ich Fenster
re-gesized habe, sah das so aus.
Okay, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal.
So sah das aus, als ich Fenster re-gesized habe
in Wayland. So.
Also, das Fenster ist...
Der Content ist nicht re-gesized,
sondern es wurde
gesoomt und der Content ist gleich
geblieben.
Das war richtig kaputt, man.
So, wir müssen übrigens
gerade bei der Gelegenheit... Habe ich noch eine
Windows-ISO hier rumliegen vielleicht?
Äh, kurz
Größe gucken.
Alter, warum ist eigentlich
nichts zu gebrauchen in Windows?
Wirklich gar nichts.
Popliches Sortieren
nach Size
funktioniert nicht, man.
Alter! Was ist das?
Kann man das nicht einfach
überhaupt nicht
croupen? Ich will es nicht croupen.
No, no. Okay.
Okay, ich habe kein
Windows 11 ISO.
Ja, das ist Layer 11.
Aber es ist auch unglaublich bescheuert gemacht.
So, Windows
11 ISO.
Hersteller. Runterladen.
Warum kann man eigentlich ein ISO für Windows 10 runterladen,
für Windows 11 runterladen, aber nicht für
Windows 10?
Versteht das
irgendjemand?
Also, man kann mit
Trick 17 natürlich auch eins runterladen für Windows 10.
Lädt das jetzt?
Ah ja, es lädt.
Alter, wie lahm ist denn das?
Warum ist das so langsam?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Konnte man hier nicht mal...
Also, mich regt diese Funktionsreduzierung
unglaublich auf.
Adresse des Links kopieren, das will ich haben.
Überall wird irgendwas rausgekürzt,
weil sie sich irgendwie denken, oh nee,
das könnte die Oma verwirren, wenn sie Chrome verwendet.
Das geht nicht, dass da ein extra Button ist.
Ich habe keinen Download Manager installiert.
Brauchen einen ordentlichen Download Manager.
Chrome.
Chrome bekommt es auf die Reihe, Windows ISO runterzuladen.
Wie ging das jetzt?
Minus J oder so?
Minus 15 oder so?
Nee, oder minus X?
Minus X?
Ah, Mann.
Ähm.
Minus...
Hä, habe ich doch gemacht.
Ah, war das minus klein J?
Oder war es vielleicht auch minus klein X?
Zack, bumm, schon gleich viel schneller, guck.
Zwei Minuten.
Wir müssen Windows mit Linux runterladen,
dann ist es schneller, als wenn wir Windows mit Windows runterladen.
Easy.
Zack, bumm.
Um nicht zu sagen...
Man muss, man muss Windows mit Linux runterladen.
Ja, aber es gab auch zu Windows 11, äh, zu Windows 10 Zeiten keinen ISO-Download.
Schickt mal einen Link zum Reeper, habe ich doch hier gezeigt gerade.
Äh, äh.
Das da.
GlazeWM.
I3, oder zumindest ein I3-inspirierter Window-Manager für Windows.
Bin echt mal gespannt, ob das...
Nein, nein, nein.
Oh, jetzt fängt es nochmal an, runterzuladen.
Das nervt mich.
Rum.
Nein.
Exit.
Runterladen, gut ist.
Ja.
Äh.
Hackermans hier wieder im Stream.
Ja, man konnte auch, was auch geht, man konnte auch mit Windows einfach den Mobilmodus im Browser aktivieren.
Also man kann ja hier, wenn man, wenn man in...
Also, ich kann es euch einfach zeigen.
Ja, guckt.
Windows 10 Download.
Man konnte auf die Windows 10 Download-Seite gehen.
Ja, da steht immer ISO-File, aber es gibt kein ISO-File.
Na gut, ging man hier auf Inspect und hat gesagt,
dass, ähm, Mobile, und dann konnte man, guckt, und dann konnte man ISO runterladen, Windows 10.
Man musste den Mobile View anmachen und ihr seht, jetzt, jetzt kann man Windows 10 ISO runterladen.
Also, man weiß nicht, was mit Microsoft abgeht, warum das vorher nicht auch geht.
Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, dass das noch so wenige kennen, ja, aber es geht.
Guckt, und wenn ihr nicht mit Mobil-Dings draufgeht, dann will es auch, bietet euch das ISO nicht an.
Microsoft-Logik, ja.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das ist komplett, das ist komplett auf, auf Windows, ja.
Also, das, das hat Windows ja tatsächlich echt vorne raus.
Die haben einfach eine Grafik-Ausgabe oder, ja, so einen Composite-Window-Gedöns-Layer dazwischen, der halt, der halt funktioniert.
Ja, und nicht so, nicht, ja, die müssen sich nicht mit X oder Wayland oder sowas rumschlagen.
So, jetzt müssen wir erst einmal, weil ich ja aus Linux Windows runtergeladen habe,
weil es schneller war als aus Windows, müssen wir erst einmal, hallo, Windows, Windows, Windows,
ich würde gern das ISO hier rauskopieren, wenn es erlaubt ist.
Windows, hallo, okay, jetzt geht einfach gar nichts mehr.
Die wollen einfach nicht, dass es, dass es schneller ist, mit Linux Windows runterzuladen, als mit Windows selbst.
Datei zu groß, doch, doch, doch.
Funktioniert, das habe ich schon oft gemacht.
Der Windows macht gerade wieder Faxen.
Mit, mit Achsen.
Ja.
Windows, Windows macht Faxen.
Guck mal.
Richtig, richtig Dead Girl ist das.
Massive Dead Girl.
Macht das überhaupt jetzt gerade was oder?
Oh.
Vor allem, wer ist richtig am Rödeln hier?
Guck mal.
Ich bin mir da jetzt nicht so sicher, ob ich, ob ich mich trauen kann, vor allem mal zu schließen oder ob's.
Traue ich mich, traue ich mich, vor allem mal abzuschießen?
Ach komm, wir warten mal kurz zwei Minuten.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kriegt es sich gleich wieder ein.
Nochmal zu der Frage von eben.
Wie kann ich denn bestenfalls verfolgen, woher der Black Screen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie du das unter Wayland am besten rauskriegst.
Also ich wüsste es unter X auch nicht, aber da hatte ich noch die Black Screens.
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist das denn hier schon wieder?
Ein 6 Gigabyte von der auf der SSD zu kopieren, ist jetzt nicht so krasser Shit, oder?
Ich. Gute Frage.
Okay, Chat geht.
Mal in mich gehen.
Hätte ich einen Laptop und ich würde laufen Black Screens, ich würde gucken, ob ich den Black Screen mit irgendwas X basiertem nicht habe.
Das ist das erste, was ich ausprobieren würde, um auszuschließen, dass es an Wayland liegt.
Und wenn es an Wayland liegt, würde ich einfach zu Google gehen und sagen Wayland Notebook Black Screen.
So.
Every second.
Dann würde ich, dann würde ich mich durch die Suchergebnisse quälen.
Okay.
er das falsch benutzt und das eigentlich überhaupt nicht
die Schuld von Wayland ist, dass das nicht geht
und fuck you Nvidia und AMD
und ihr seid alle kacke und Wayland ist das geilste
und jetzt stell dich mal nicht so an, du solltest
eigentlich froh darüber sein
dass du es benutzen darfst und
stell dich nicht so an, dass du eine Sekunde
Blackscreen hast, so was
wirst du dann wahrscheinlich früher oder später finden
ok Leute, ich muss anscheinend echt
Forever Neustarten
das hat
das hat's destroyed
ok, ich hoffe
Forever startet jetzt wieder richtig
ok, das hat schon mal funktioniert
ach ja
ich hätte mal
meinen Download weiterlaufen
lassen sollen unter Windows
Leute hier
ach guck mal, unter Windows ist es jetzt auch schneller
das musst du erst mal sehen
dass es unter Linux schneller ist
so dass es jetzt unter Windows
auch schnell ist, alles klar
ja, wisst ihr was?
dann lösche ich das einfach unter Linux wieder
und probiere dieses komische Track und Drop erst
gar nicht
ja, das ist natürlich nicht verkehrt
das stimmt schon, irgendwelche Logs gucken
ich würde auf jeden Fall ausprobieren
ob ich es unter X auch hab
kann man Ubuntu noch mit X starten?
ein neues?
Ubuntu, frisch installiert
hat das noch eine X-Session?
irgendwie, geht das?
wahrscheinlich nicht
eine Session alleine reicht ja nicht
muss das ja auch alles installiert haben
also Ubuntu hat noch ein X
drunter, dann würde ich das mal tatsächlich direkt
mit X starten, anstatt mit Wayland
übrigens
nur mal zu der Erklärung
warum ich so eine Abneigung gegen Wayland hab
ich verwende ja zum Beispiel ganz gerne
hier meine Linux-VM
und wenn ihr jetzt mal guckt
auf GitHub
dann gibt es wieder eine große Diskussion drüber
dass Wayland in einer VM
nicht richtig funktioniert, weil
also das Problem ist
und ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen
Wayland
refresht den Screen nicht
in einer VM
also ihr könnt euch vorstellen
das bedeutet, du kannst den
du kannst das nicht benutzen, weil
wenn das Screen nicht refreshed
heißt das, es wird nichts angezeigt
der einzige, also auch kein Mauszeiger bewegen oder so
das einzige den Screen refresh zu bekommen ist
zwischen
zwischen Terminal und
und ähm
GUI Session zu wechseln
dann refresht das Screen
man kann das ganze überschreiten
mit einer mit einer software rendering oder sowas environment variable das funktioniert und dann
geht das ja ich gehe ich habe es auch gemerkt schon dass das mit ubuntu wayland funktioniert
ich gehe davon aus dass das dass das irgendwas anders macht als wenn man einfach nur sway oder
so in wayland starten will es gibt aber auch wayland vmware refresh gibt es gibt es auch
ein ticket zu wenn wills wayland support ach so copy paste funktioniert ja auch nicht habe
ich ganz vergessen copy copy paste ist ja auch kaputt mit wayland unter vm oder ist das speziell
das ist ein vmware problem ja ja das ist vmware problem das ding ist halt das ist mal wieder die
gleiche diskussion die gleiche scheiß diskussion gibt wie mit so vielen linux projekten es wird
sich jahrelang
darüber diskutiert wer jetzt schuld ist und wer das jetzt implementieren muss die wayland leute
sagen auch nur das machen wir nicht vmware ist es vollkommen egal die treiberhersteller die
interessiert das ganze auch nicht und dann schieben sie sich das alle 33 jahre ach 33 jahre untereinander
zu und irgendwann kommt dann mal keine ahnung der ceo von ubuntu und stellt fest auf seinem
laptop funktioniert es nicht und steckt dann zwei
millionen rein und dann geht es auf einmal also das ist wirklich voll für nash was da teilweise
abgeht aber so ist es halt da muss man sich dran gewöhnen das ist die gleiche die gleiche diskussion
leute erinnert sich noch guck mal jetzt mal ohne scheiß was meint ihr wie lange geht hardware
decoding von videos auf youtube unter windows schon also was ich damit meine ist wie lange
könnt ihr eure grafikkarte schon zum videos gucken auf youtube verwenden unter windows also so dass ihr
nicht 80 prozent cpu last auf einem kern habt sondern das ganze decodet wird von der grafikkarte
wie lange geht das schon das geht mindestens seit 2013 mindestens seit 2013 aber einem vorverletzten
pc ging das schon wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich er 15 jahre wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich geht
das seit 2005 oder so seit xbox release irgendwann 2007 oder sowas schon dass das geht seit 15 jahren
Und unter Linux geht das erst seit einem Jahr halbwegs und dann auch nur in der passenden Kombination von, du musst das Video erwischen mit dem richtigen Codec, du brauchst die richtige Browser-Version, du brauchst die richtige Mesa-Treiber-Version, du brauchst die richtige Grafikkarte und die richtigen Grafikkarten-Treiber dafür und dann, wenn du Glück hast, funktioniert es und dann brauchst du noch ein Browser-Plugin, was natürlich die Videos auf YouTube forst auf H.264, weil VP9 zwischenzeitlich einfach mal wieder kaputt gegangen ist.
Oh, ey, das ist so für'n Arsch, man. Linux ist toll, aber auf dem Desktop wird das nix, Leute. Auf dem Desktop, es können noch so viele Leute sagen, bald ist das Jahr des Linux-Desktops. Die kriegen diesen ganzen Kram einfach nicht geschissen. Ja, das ist auch ein gutes Beispiel dafür immer.
So, was macht eigentlich mein Download hier? Ah, gleich fertig. Nice. Kann man nach einer halben Stunde anfangen. Das ist ja noch relativ schnell für meine Verhältnisse.
Ja, Firefox sind eh die geilsten, die einfach mal ihren H.264-Decoder für Android entfernt haben, random, weil sie keinen Bock mehr haben.
So, ISO ist fertig, downgeloadet. Nein. Nein. Nein, das hat mit HTML5 überhaupt nichts zu tun. Es geht um Hardware-Decoding, dass die Grafikkarte die Videos decodet.
Und das ging bis vor... Das geht teilweise in manchen Konstellationen immer noch nicht. So, dann legen wir doch mal... Wie viel Platz hab ich denn wo? Hab ich auf C genug Platz?
C? Ja, locker. Easy, easy. Jetzt wird es wieder kompliziert, eine Windows-11-Kiste anzulegen. Also, für einmal Workstation 17. Ja, ich mach das später.
Wir installieren Windows 11. Wir wollen das hier unter Documents, Virtual Machine. Ja, meinetwegen, ganz toll.
So, jetzt muss man ein Passwort eingeben, weil ansonsten nicht Windows-11-kompatibel. Warum auch immer. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, geht nicht.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, geht nicht. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, geht nicht.
TPM macht er automatisch mit dem Preset mittlerweile.
UEFI, Secure Boot. Ich glaube, Secure Boot brauchen wir gar nicht mehr.
Number of Processors, eins. Number of Core, sechs. Ist Windows 11, brauchen wir ein bisschen Power.
16 GB RAM sollte reichen.
NAT, das ist gut. NVMe, ist gut.
Create New Virtual Disk, 64GB ist auch gut. Single File.
Windows 10, so.
Printer weg.
Das ist okay.
So, dann hängen wir jetzt mal das ISO rein.
Installieren wir mal schnell Windows 10.
Dann kann ich mich, das kann ich ja jetzt schon sagen, kann ich mich bei der Windows 11, äh Windows 11 installieren, nicht Windows 10.
Kann ich mich bei der Windows 11 Installation wieder aufregen, weil ich mir nicht merken kann, wie man das ohne Microsoft Account installieren macht.
Da musste man irgendwie die Konsole öffnen und irgendeinen Blödsinn eingeben, dass es dann funktioniert hat.
Aber glücklicherweise ist der Chat so high IQ, dass der Chat das immer weiß.
Der Chat sagt mir dann immer, wie das funktioniert.
Da muss man eine Konsole aufmachen und dann muss man eingeben, irgendwie OOB oder sowas.
Ey, ne, Internet weg ist nicht notwendig.
OOBE, Bypass, NRO.
Obviously muss man das machen.
Ich finde, das ist vollkommen klar.
Und ja, also.
Wer das nicht weiß, ist schon ganz schön cringe, oder?
Wem das nicht klar ist, dass er das eingeben muss.
So, Language to install, Englisch, United Kingdom, Time and Currency.
Es ist eh egal, was man hier auswählt.
Keyboard, Urdu.
Ja, das ist es, Leute.
Genau, Internet weg gibt es nämlich Probleme.
Das hatte ich auch so im Hinterkopf.
Was ist das gebraucht?
Was, Urdu?
Keyboard Layout?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal.
Auf welchem Teil, noch nicht mal auf welchem Kontinent, man Urdu brauchen würde, wahrscheinlich Afrika, wo man das brauchen würde, als Keyboard Layout.
Warum sieht der Insta da immer noch scheiße aus?
Tja, weil das Microsoft am Arsch vorbeigeht.
Next.
Ja, ja, OOB ist Out of Box Experience.
Die Microsoft Benahmung von Dingern, ich habe, ich habe aufgegeben, es irgendwie zu hinterfragen, warum was wie heißt.
Eine Firma einrichten, dann stattdessen einer Domäne beitreten, reicht doch, um lokalen Account zu haben.
Echt?
Soll ich mal ausprobieren?
Okay, ich gucke jetzt nach, wo man Urdu Sprache, wo spricht man Urdu?
Urdu ist die Nationalsprache Pakistans, sowie eine der Amtssprachen Indiens.
Ah, also quasi Peter von Microsoft Support.
Verstehe.
Sorry, von Microsoft Gold Support natürlich.
Warum lädst du dir nicht die fertigen VMs von Microsoft runter?
Gute Frage, weil ich nicht wusste, dass es welche gibt.
Wo gibt es denn welche?
Das bedeutet, Urdu ist vermutlich das häufigste Layout.
Bestimmt, bestimmt eines der häufigsten, ja.
Die, die haben viele Leute.
Ich schicke dir einen Link.
Oh, boah, bin mal gespannt, was jetzt kommt.
Microsoft.to oder so.
Ah, ne, tatsächlich.
Wait a minute.
Gibt es wirklich?
Hä?
Da guck an.
Es ist auch, es ist auch keine.
Es ist auch keine Fake-Adresse.
Das ist ja, dass wir irgendwie gebetet werden oder so.
Interessant.
Lädt er jetzt direkt runter oder was?
Hallo?
Ich habe gerade geklickt, da wollten die abbrechen.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Wisst ihr, ich sollte einfach die VM behalten und mal einen Snapshot machen.
Dann wäre das ganz einfach.
Aber das war mir auch neu.
In welchem Format gibt es denn die eigentlich?
Okay, Parallels, Virtual Box, Hyper-V.
Wer auch immer sich das gibt, freiwillig und VM-Wer.
Oh, dann verkehrt.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, dass sie das machen.
Oh, es ist schon fertig.
Guck mal hier.
Das ging aber richtig schnell jetzt.
Is this the right country or region?
Wir sollten tatsächlich.
Okay, das ist, das ist okay.
Ja, ja.
Yes, yes.
Beste.
Keyboard Layout.
Ne.
Wisst ihr, was mich auch übelst triggert?
Dass man hier nicht.
Man kann nur scrollen.
Man kann hier nicht irgendwie G drücken, dass man da.
Das ist, das ist so, ah, so, so, so zusammengestückelt alles.
Ja, Elfensprache.
Skip.
Und jetzt müssen wir erst mal 50 mal auswählen, dass wir nicht getrackt werden wollen.
Moment, Leute, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Warum durfte ich installieren, ohne dass ich einen Account eingeben muss?
Ah, ne, das kommt noch.
Das kommt noch, ne.
Das kommt noch.
Hack Wait heißt das.
Das Ding jetzt.
Warum muss man das Keyboard Layout auswählen, nur um dann das Keyboard Layout auszuwählen?
Die Frage stelle ich mir auch jedes Mal.
Weil die es anscheinend nicht in der Lage sind, zwischen Installer und installiertem OS zu kommunizieren, was man für ein Keyboard Layout ausgewählt hat.
Kennt wer eigentlich eine gute Alternative zu CentOS?
Ja, entweder Geld für Red Hat ausgeben oder gibt zwei Sachen.
Aber die sind bei weitem natürlich nicht so erprobt wie CentOS, weil, naja, war bisher auch nicht notwendig.
Alma und Rocky.
Weiß ich aber nicht, was zur Zeit da die bevorzugte Sache ist.
Na, Debian ist keine Alternative.
Es geht ja um Red Hat Clones.
Was ist denn zur Zeit beliebter?
Alma Linux oder Rocky Linux?
Echt?
Ich hab das nicht verfolgt.
Nehmen fünf Leute dran teil.
Sonst keinen interessiert.
Was?
Okay, irgendjemand hat doch geschrieben, man braucht das nicht mehr.
Was soll ich jetzt machen?
Setup for personal use?
Oder was soll ich machen, ohne OOB-Experience-Dingsen zu müssen?
For work und dann Domain.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Sign in options?
Domain join instead.
Okay.
Next?
Kann man das Passwort nicht einfach weglassen?
Doch.
Nun.
Moment.
Das war's?
Man muss dieses OOB-Shit gar nicht machen?
Ja, okay.
Nein, keine Location.
Nein, kein Device.
Nein.
Okay.
Ist das weniger geworden?
Ist das weniger?
Früher kam immer an der Stelle jetzt,
Hi, I'm Cortana.
Glücklicherweise ist der Shit weg, ey.
So, und dann erst mal VMware-Tools drauf und dann können wir's ausprobieren.
Man kann Cortana sogar deins...
Ich glaube, Cortana ist gar nicht mehr dabei.
Oh, doch.
Öh, öh.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz Cortana überfahren.
Kann man das nicht?
Muss richtig positioniert sein.
Okay.
Shit!
Cortana crabt den Fokus.
Hahaha.
Das Startmenü.
Und auf dem zweiten Dis...
Moment, ich muss Cortana outplayen.
Moment, Moment.
Cortana muss outplayed werden.
Sekunde.
Muss auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Fuck!
Leute, das Startmenü hat hyper super
Top-Window-Fokus.
Da geht nix drüber.
Ich hab's grad vom anderen Display getriggert.
Normalerweise
rendern meine Bilder
on top über alles drüber. Aber das Startmenü...
ist wahrscheinlich so high-priority,
da kann man nicht drüber rendern.
Okay, VM.
Install VMware Tools.
Ja.
Wenn ich Windows 11
schon sehe im Default-Modus,
da dreh ich immer...
dreh ich immer durch.
VS. Ja.
Genau, es hat Z-Index
9 Milliarden.
Backup von der VM
als Vorlage.
Ich hab mir das überlegt, brauch ich doch nicht, weil
das nächste Mal ist irgendein komischer
Patch von Microsoft raus
und dann brauch ich länger den Patch zu upgraden
als neu von der ISO,
der aktuellen ISO zu entzielen.
Was sind das eigentlich für komische Punkte hier?
Search the Solar System.
Nerv einfach nicht,
Microsoft.
Macht den ganzen Scheiß einfach weg.
Was hat die höhere Priorität?
Task Manager oder...
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Man kann das nicht richtig testen.
Weil der dann nicht fokussiert bleibt.
Kann man...
Er always on top.
Okay.
Der Task Manager hat Priorität.
Task Manager ist
always on top, Gachibas.
Der kennt da nix.
Wenn man in der Domain ist, kann da das Firmen-Logo
stehen. Das fanden unsere Chefs unfassbar geil.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Auf so Kleingram, da stehen die schon.
Ja, das finden die geil.
So, Searchbox, Hide.
Ähm...
Und jetzt das ganze, please
Alignen.
Left.
Kann man eigentlich angroupen schon?
Oder ist das noch nicht raus?
Ich glaub, das ist noch nicht raus, dass man...
Oder ist das raus?
Moment, gucken wir mal.
Ob das das ist.
Hey!
Ich mein, es ist halt maximal
hässlich gemacht, aber
es funktioniert.
So, und jetzt müssen wir, ganz wichtig,
Dark Theme.
Ging das nicht auch
unaktiviert?
Ich bilde mir ein, dass
Theme-Einstellungen gingen doch auch bisher immer
unaktiviert.
Naja, anscheinend nicht.
Pass mal auf, ich hab ne Idee.
Wo, wo ist der, wo ist der
Copilot?
Ist das mittlerweile schon drinne in Windows?
Wie mach ich diesen
komischen Copilot auch noch nicht?
Ah, weil den Copilot konnte man fragen
dafür. Aber...
Wie dem auch sei.
So.
OM.
Moment, wo war das jetzt nochmal? View Exclusive Mode.
Brauch ich sonst, sonst
spackt der rum mit Tastenshortcuts.
Okay, als erstes
erstmal...
Geh weg!
Erstmal Firefox downloaden.
Okay, ich seh,
der Chat ist... Firefox download
opera.com. Ja, ist
klar. Nice, nice Ergebnisse.
Ich will,
ich will Firefox nicht auf
Deutsch runterladen. Ich hätte gerne
Firefox auf
Englisch.
Aber Mozilla hat
keinen Bock, so wie es aussieht.
Englisch.
Stimmt! Wir haben ja
Winget jetzt. Ich vergesse
das immer. Terminal.
Winget.
Winget install
Firefox.
Ich hab immer noch, warum, wenn ich manchmal so komische
Zeug tippe.
Das liegt daran, dass ich immer noch
Pflaster am Finger hab.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt ist es broken, oder was?
Nice.
Und jetzt ist meine Shell auf einmal blau.
Kann da einfach
irgendwas funktionieren, man?
Okay, geht Chrome.
Das ist so eine Krücke,
dieses System, ey.
Ich glaub, wir installieren WSL, das ist für uns besser.
Wie kann man diesen
Bullshit einfach nur verwenden? Ich versteh's nicht.
Firefox Download.
Na gut, man kommt halt nicht drum herum.
Warum kann ich das nicht auf
Englisch bekommen?
E-N, Download. Ja, beste.
Download Firefox.
WSLG hat
Schnittstelle für grafische Sachen.
Aber WSLG hat auch so seine Probleme.
Warum ist Winget
eigentlich jetzt auf einmal kaputt?
Sollen wir mal GitHub zum Beispiel.
Hä?
Winget
broken
broken Winget after installing Windows 11
and all its updates
last week
Vielleicht geht das mit der neuen PowerShell.
Das ist doch, ach so,
ja, das ist doch PowerShell.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht liegt's auch
vielleicht, wir machen's mal mit CMD.
Winget search
Firefox
Fox
Ne.
Oh, das ist so schlecht
alles, man.
Keine Updates available.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht muss ich updaten.
Okay, okay, okay, vielleicht muss ich updaten.
Jetzt ist die Frage,
updatet man Winget über Windows Update
oder über den Windows Store?
Man weiß's
ja nicht so genau.
Dieses Betriebssystem ist so eine krasse
Zumutung, man.
Wo erkenne, wo sehe ich überhaupt,
ob es Updates im Store gibt?
Wo sehe ich das überhaupt?
Get updates, hier.
Okay, restart required.
Und jetzt, hier weiß man ja nicht, was er
macht.
Microsoft ist der Meinung, dass ein blauer
Button mit nem Spinner drauf
komplett genug
Informationen sind, dass man versteht, was
hier vor sich geht gerade.
Sagt euch auch dieser blaue Sp...
Ah, ach so, natürlich, jetzt ist alles klar.
Es ist einfacher
zu programmieren. Ja, den Eindruck hab ich...
Alter, wie viel kommt da bitteschön
über den Store, man? Und, und,
warum macht Windows Update nicht automatisch
Ich will's gar nicht wissen.
Komm, ist egal. Cortana!
Jawoll, endlich! Glück!
Leute, danke
Microsoft, Cortana wird geupdatet
und MSN Weather und Microsoft People.
Was ist Microsoft
People überhaupt?
Das ist, das ist so
unsinnig, dass es nicht mal,
dass du nicht mal starten kannst im Taskmenü.
Ecliptchamp ist auch
am Start, ja.
Ich wart immer noch auf die
Überweisung von Microsoft.
Dein iPhone
macht doch auch App-Updates
separat vom... Ja, das stimmt.
Aber der macht's auch automatisch.
Da muss ich nicht
in App-Store klicken, den ich eh nicht
benutzen will.
Ich kann kein Dark Mode anmachen, weil ich Windows nicht
aktiviert hab.
Außer Viva... Moment, okay, okay, Chat geht.
Viva noch mal...
Dark Mode aktivieren
geht ohne, sag mal wie, sag mal wie.
Irgendjemand hat eben vorhin
Registry-Hack gepostet.
Aber ich mach keine random Registry-Sachen
aus dem Chat.
Was jetzt?
Ist der Store gecrashed gerade
oder was?
Zu viel Sachen, die sich
geupdatet haben und gleichzeitig...
Ach, der Store hat sich geupdatet.
Ach so.
Solitär, endlich, endlich.
Rechtsklick
auf dem Desktop und dann, wie man's normal
macht. Nee, nee, das geht nicht mehr.
Normal gehst du hier Personalize,
sagst
Themes
und dann kannst du sagen
äh...
Moment.
Wo ist denn das überhaupt jetzt?
Dark Theme.
Ja, geht nicht, weil
weil you need to activate.
Yentari, mach
meine random Registry-Sachen.
Ah, okay.
Mal gucken.
Ach, Moment.
Hä?
Da geht das?
Aber da geht das nicht.
Oh, Mann.
Das ist so dumm alles.
Das tut immer so weh, wenn ich
den Scheiß benutzen muss, Mann.
Das ist einfach...
Das ist eine komplette Zumutung der Scheiß, Mann.
Das macht einen ja fertig.
Das muss hier in die Mitte und ein bisschen
größer.
Microsoft Support eröffnet.
Ja, klar.
Hat das jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Ja, oder?
Okay, ich will jetzt wissen, was Microsoft
People ist. Guck mal!
Der hat Microsoft People geupdatet.
Und wenn ich nach...
Wenn ich da nach suche, finde das nicht mal.
Dafür, dafür habe ich...
Bestimmt
wieder Disney Plus oder so ein Shit drauf.
Oder... Ja, geht eigentlich.
Spotify,
WhatsApp, okay.
So, jetzt muss ich neu starten, weil
er sagt ja...
Restart. Das ist die Kontakte-App.
Ja, ist gut, dass die im Store
Microsoft People heißt, aber im
Startmenü dann Kontakte.
Das ist wichtig,
dass man den Zusammenhang nicht erkennt.
Contacts. Immer immer Contacts
findet er bei mir.
Okay, kann ich es jetzt
endlich ausprobieren? Okay, wir haben es
geschafft, Leute. Wir haben es geschafft. Nice.
Checking for updates. Oh,
es geht weiter. Eben waren
wir angeblich noch up to date.
Ach, jetzt kommen nur noch die neuesten Virus-
Definitionen. Das ist okay, das
darf.
Die Sounds sind angenehmer. Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist korrekt.
View exclusive.
Download and install.
Kommulativ
update preview. Nein, nein, nein,
nein. Genug
kumuliert.
Kommulativ make primary browser.
Ja.
Okay, also
Glaze WM GitHub.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das funktioniert.
Releases. Guck mal, das
letzte Release ist vom
September.
Das ist sogar relativ neu.
Zwei Monate oder so alt.
In was ist denn das
programmiert?
Hoffentlich Blazingly Fast written in Rust.
Ach nee, C Sharp. Okay, dann
könnte es ja tatsächlich was
taugen.
x64. Ach, jetzt soll ich mal
Winged ausprobieren.
Winged search Firefox.
Okay, jetzt
funktioniert Winged. Ich bin aber,
es ist aber geil, dass es
Windows 11 ausgeliefert mit einer
Winged Version, die einfach komplett broken ist.
Warum
genau findet er das bei Firefox?
Ich meine, ich finde, dass
Floor P Lightning, Blaze Floor
P Lightning nicht nach Firefox
klingt. Tag Firefox Fork.
Okay.
Was auch immer das ist.
Hat der Download funktioniert?
Okay, install.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Run anyway.
MyVM
now.
Wie das einfach hinterm Fenster war.
No config file found.
At keck Glaze WM Config YAML.
Create new config file
from starter template. Okay.
So, jetzt muss ich mir aber ein bisschen die...
Hat er denn jetzt gleich
gestartet oder so?
Excellent, excellent.
So.
Äh.
Okay.
Das hat leider keine
i3...
Das hat leider keine i3
Shortcuts. Da muss ich erstmal
in die Shortcuts reingucken.
Wie switcht... Ah ja.
Mit Alt-Taste switcht man zwischen
Desktops. Okay.
Da muss ich mich dran gewöhnen.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier mal ein Terminal
starten. Oh, okay. Das ist das gleiche.
Ich kann Terminal
starten. Wir sollten
uns mal... Wir sollten uns mal
die Config angucken.
Tja. Okay.
Passt mal auf. PowerShell-Skills, Leute.
Jetzt kommt's.
PowerShell. Also.
CD Glaze
WM
Vim Config keckel. Ah, das gibt's ja nicht.
Moment. Gibt's? Ne.
Less Config YAML.
Ach, ne. Äh.
More. Ah ja. Das geht.
Okay. Können wir das nicht einfach...
Okay. Wir brauchen Whistles. Okay.
Vim Get in...
Vim Get Search.
Ah ja. Autocomplete geht natürlich nicht.
Okay.
Vim Get
Install. Was?
Hab ich aber nicht angeklickt.
Warum nicht Vim? Weil wir unter Windows
sind. Ah. Die Floating
Dinger macht er auch als Teil. Okay.
Ja, das macht I3 teilweise
auch. Aber
ich hab's bei den meisten Sachen, die Popups
sind, eingestellt bei meinem I3, dass der
das nicht macht.
Ich weiß, dass Vim ganz gut unter Windows funktioniert.
So. Also.
Code.
Ah, ne. Man musste das erst schließen. Ja. Und jetzt...
Und wenn man's nochmal aufmacht,
dann geht's, glaub ich. Code.
Okay. Das finde ich doch schon mal gar net so.
Gar net so
verkehrt. So. Wie verschiebt
man das jetzt auf... Aha.
Aha. Okay. Guckt.
Aber das Switchen zwischen
Desktops ist schon ein bisschen
cringe. Okay.
Was kann man hier einstellen?
Fokus.
Nein. Automatisch Fokus ist doof.
Sekunde.
Ähm.
Settings.
Äh. Ne.
Config. Chase. Ach. Wie war das?
Hieß das nicht Settings?
Ist jetzt total bescheuert.
Ich muss
das Settings?
Ach. Preferences hieß das.
Preferences.
Font.
18.
Äh. Schon besser.
20.
Ah. Das ist gut.
Also. Ich muss sagen.
Eine Sache hat Microsoft richtig gemacht.
Consolas ist ein nicer Font.
So. Also. Gaps.
Gaps machen wir schon ein bisschen kleiner. 5 reicht.
Und Outer Gap 5 reicht auch.
Quasi ein Gap zwischen den Fenstern
und ein Gap außenrum.
5 reicht. Äh. Gibt es sowas wie
Reload? Aha.
Okay. Nice. Er hat
so eine Art I3 Keybindings.
Da kann man nur mit Alt
anstatt mit Windows Taste.
Was glaube
ich unter Windows gar nicht so
verkehrt ist?
Kann mir Bing da helfen so?
Ne.
VS Code will Links unten updaten.
Wo? Hier? Ne.
Wo will das updaten?
Hier.
Moment. Ich habe das doch gerade
eben installiert.
War das eine ältere
ältere Version in WinGet
oder wie?
Meine Güte.
Moment. Es war älter als Oktober.
Strongly
recommended to set to false.
Globally enabled
distal window transition anime. Set
strongly
to false.
Ja ist glaube ich
auch sinniger.
Hat aber immer noch
hat aber immer noch
animations.
Wie man hier
sieht. Ich meine
besser als, besser als nix.
Focus Border, Bar.
Was hat man
hier oben eigentlich?
Hier oben hat man die Tray Icons
oder so. Weil man hat jetzt
man hat jetzt unten die Taskleiste
und oben so eine Leiste.
Da fragt man sich
natürlich.
Für was ist das?
Da fragt man sich natürlich
wozu?
Ja das sind hier meine.
Ist das das USB
Icon oder wie?
Ok die Leiste oben ist komplett unsinnig.
Die braucht niemand.
OneDrive weg. Close.
Jawoll. Das hier oben braucht
also dann verwende ich
lieber die Tray Icons da unten.
Ganz ehrlich.
Wobei, wobei
hier kann man Config
neu laden. Aber das bringt ja überhaupt nix.
Weil ich
reload die ja schon mit Shift Alt R
hab ich die ganze Zeit schon gemacht.
Das da oben braucht man
anscheinend wirklich nur um Desktops
zu switchen.
Deswegen wäre es eigentlich ganz gut
hätten sie es irgendwie geschafft
das in die Taskleiste zu integrieren.
Die Anzeige vom Desktop. Dann bräuchte man
diese Bar da oben nicht.
So ist das bisschen doppel gemoppelt.
Holz? Musst du in Anführungszeichen?
Ne. Muss nicht.
Muss hier oben ja auch nicht.
Ok hier steht das auch ohne.
Oder meinst du ernsthaft ich soll Anf-
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ne macht doch nix.
Windows Taskleiste hat ein Desktop Switch Icon.
Moment ist denn?
Moment.
Das sind keine Windows
Das sind keine Windows Desktops hier die ich da sehe.
Das ist eigenes
Windows Handling.
Warte mal Task View.
Guck das sind keine
Windows Desktops.
Windows Desktops kann
ich auch haben.
Die sich aber nicht switchen lassen
mehr. Dann.
Also ich kann jetzt I3
Ich kann den jetzt gestartet haben auf jedem
Desktop.
Auf jedem Windows
Okay das ist ein bisschen zu abgedreht.
Oh da kommt er durcheinander.
Da kommt er durcheinander.
Da blickt er dann immer durch.
Das ist das.
Das kann man nicht zusammen verwenden.
Das checkt er nicht mehr.
Ok Windows Desktops darf man nicht verwenden.
Was aber schon ein bisschen
doof ist.
Das es nicht mit Windows Desktops implementiert ist.
Highlight Active Inactive Windows
Component Left Workspace
ist hier haben wir.
Component Center Windows
Teil. Ok das man sieht was
auf ist.
Braucht man eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht.
Habe ich unter I3 auch nicht.
Guckt.
Was interessiert mich.
Ob da oben steht welche Anwendung
ich offen habe. Ich sehe es ja.
Ich habe es hier direkt vor der Nase.
Ich verwende Windows Desktops immer.
Guckt zum Beispiel hierfür.
Zwischen 4M und Host.
System Tray.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht was
der Button da eben macht.
Also die Leiste hier oben ist bis auf die Desktop Anzeigen
eigentlich komplett überflüssig.
Weil die Taskleiste ist ja auch noch da.
Und die Taskleiste wirst du wahrscheinlich
auch brauchen. Weil du willst ja vielleicht mal
was anklicken hier was man da nicht unbedingt
machen kann. Rechts und so.
Also.
Also ehrlich gesagt ist das. Es wäre
cooler sie hätten die
Desktop Anzeige
als Overlay von der Taskleiste gemacht.
Dann hätte man sich hier oben
nämlich die Leiste sparen können.
Ne Taskleiste ausblenden
bringt ja nichts.
Du willst ja schon ab und zu mal auf irgendwelche Sachen hier unten
zugreifen. Sei es so Netzwerksettings,
Soundlautstärke und sowas.
Das da oben müsste eigentlich weg.
Und ganz ehrlich
das da oben kann auch weg.
Nur die Desktop Anzeige worauf man
ist braucht man noch.
Vielleicht kann man, ach guck mal
die Bar kann man auch Bottom
machen vielleicht. Ah ne.
Ok.
Die ist dann über. Das ist.
Ich hab gehofft die Overlay die Taskleiste
vielleicht. Kann man die
Bar Left machen?
Was eigentlich wenig Sinn macht aber.
Ne nochmal Top.
Irgendwie ist es.
Leute es ist kaputt.
Es reloadet.
Ich glaube es ist gecrashed.
Ich glaube es ist kaputt.
Es ist gecrashed.
Oh ne mein Tastatur Layout
ist geswitcht auf
ähm jetzt ist es wieder
es ist wieder da.
Äh.
Was kann man sonst machen?
Ok das konnte man Bottom
einstellen. Das ging ne ja.
Und dann konnte man was sagen?
Offset. Was macht denn Offset
X?
Ok ja das ist so. Und Offset Y?
Minus? Minus?
Äh bringt nix.
Das Overlay
leider nicht die Taskleiste.
Das könnte man tatsächlich noch ganz gut
gebrauchen. Time Format
juckt nicht. Workplace Names.
Ignore Screen Clipping
Host.
Und Task Manager.
Ok das funktioniert. Task Manager
floated weiterhin. Ganz gut.
Resize.
Da merkt man halt das man doch unter Windows
ist. Ja man kann Fenster resizen.
Die dann halt einfach wieder groß gemacht werden.
Weil man eigentlich nicht resizen darf.
Wenn ich das
bei meinem Linux i3 probiere
dann passiert folgendes.
Er macht entweder
gar nichts.
Ja. Oder er resized
halt den Split
wie das aufgeteilt ist.
Und erst wenn ich Floating mache
kann ich es richtig resizen.
Also hier einfach resizen geht halt nicht.
Merkt man halt das das unter Windows nicht
dafür gedacht ist. Ok
Vim Resize Keybindings
Focus Left Focus
Right.
Kann man auch hier
kann man zum Beispiel jetzt auch
Terminal aufmachen und hier zwischendurch
skippen. Das finde ich ganz nice.
Das ist unter i3 auch nice.
Dann
Move Windows. Ja das mache ich
so gut wie nie. Aber es geht ähnlich.
Shift Alt Left. Shift Alt Right.
Nur das es halt bei meinem i3
Windows Taste ist anstatt Alt.
Sind die Animationen jetzt weg?
Gute Frage. Ja. Die Animationen
sind weg. Ihr musst einfach.
Außer in der Taskleiste. Die Taskleiste
ist komplett am ausflippen. Guckt euch das mal an.
Die Taskleiste kackt
komplett ab.
Das da ist komplett am abkacken.
Alt U
Alt P
Achso da kann man. Ok.
Das mache ich immer
immer hier mit. Bisschen laggy.
Aber das liegt bestimmt an der VM das laggy ist.
So dann haben wir noch
Tiling Direction
und so. Das benutze ich unter i3 auch seltenst.
Ach Alt Shift Q
Das habe ich Visual Studio Code
beendet. Lul. Alt Shift Q
Glaze VM Alt Shift E
Ist das gleiche. Reload Config
Deswegen habe ich das auch eben ohne Probleme
gefunden.
Alt Enter Terminal. Jo.
Focus to Workspace.
Ok. Ja.
Alt 1 2 3 4
5. Ja.
Übliche. Das wars.
Also ich finde das gar nicht mal so übel.
Bis jetzt.
Man muss halt sagen es integriert sich
wirklich nicht so.
Ich sage noch ich finde es ganz gut.
Jetzt starte ich Firefox.
Firefox hat einfach keinen Bock da drauf.
Ah ja. Ok.
Wenn man Firefox einmal gesagt hat
du sollst es jetzt machen dann geht es auch.
Aber wenn man Firefox
einfach. Anscheinend
hat sich das Firefox gemerkt und mag jetzt doch.
Lass uns mal ein bisschen kurz
auf GitHub gucken.
Schieben wir den Editor
mal auf 2. So wie ich das unter auch habe.
Also eigentlich habe ich
Shell auf 2. Editor auf
3. Und
unter Linux Browser auf 1.
Also hier haben wir einen Browser.
Hier haben wir Shell. Hier haben wir Editor.
Ja passt doch eigentlich ganz gut.
So was kann man denn da jetzt so alles machen noch?
Direct Download. Finger Scoop.
Roadmap. Full Roadmap. Ok.
Was haben die noch so vor?
Viel.
Issues gucken.
Ah. Mehr Issues als der
Fiat Champ. Das ist
immer ein gutes Zeichen.
Ich bin mir übrigens gar nicht. Lass mich mal kurz
checken wie viele Issues gibt es da.
23 immer noch. Oh da gibt es einen Puls.
Ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Ihr seht meine
Open Source Projekte sind super gepflegt.
23 Issues
einfach am Start.
Und kein Bock
irgendwas zu machen.
Ja das haben wir ja schon gemacht.
Ja die Bar haben wir auch schon konfiguriert.
Aber die Bar finde ich
Die Bar finde ich eigentlich total überflüssig.
Die braucht man nicht.
Ich bin fast geneigt
die Bar auszuplenden.
Ob ich im Desktop bin weiß ich auch so.
Und der Platzverlust hier ist es
eigentlich nicht wert.
Ja Bar Enabled eigentlich
eigentlich False.
Wo war das hier?
Mit der Bar. Gibt es so was?
Kann man die Bar
Irgendwie
Taskleiste ausblenden.
Taskleiste ausblenden bringt überhaupt nichts.
Du brauchst Taskleiste hier wenn du mal
irgendwelche Settings willst. Wenn du mal die Lautstärke
anpassen willst. Dann lieber die andere
Bar. Also
Disablen kann man das anscheinend nicht.
Ach doch.
Ich bin doch ganz fett da.
Enable True. Lul.
Alter erstmal.
Enable False.
Zack. Nice.
Ja so finde ich das deutlich
angenehmer.
Ich weiß eh auf welchem Desktop ich bin.
Wisst ihr unter meiner Linux
unter meiner Linux VM. Da hat die Bar ja noch irgendwie
einen Sinn. Die zeigt mir nicht nur an
auf welchem Desktop ich bin.
Das ist ja schön und gut. Das bräuchte ich nicht unbedingt.
Aber hier habe ich ja meinen
Tray und so ein paar Infos
über mein System. So ob ich zum Beispiel so blöd war
und hab numlog wieder gedrückt.
Disk
Usage. Ich kann hier
Timer starten wenn ich
an was erinnert werden will.
Und CPU Auslastung kann ich hier oben
in meiner Bar auch anzeigen. Finde ich übrigens extrem
nice.
Guck mal.
Da sind die CPU Kerne hier oben die angezeigt werden.
Das sehe ich wenn
ein Kern hängt. Wie verrückt.
Ich mach gerade ein bisschen Random Terminal
Ausgabe. Jetzt ist es wieder abgebrochen.
Zack.
Das finde ich sehr praktisch. Da sieht man immer
ob im Hintergrund irgendwas grödelt.
Also wir haben glaube ich. Aha.
Guck mal. Da gibt es noch mehr Sachen für die
für die Bar. Man kann Batterie
anzeigen lassen. CPU Usage.
GPU Usage.
Memory Usage Network.
Aber ich glaube trotzdem
das Wetter. Ok. Besser als
die Windows Wetter Anzeige wird es wahrscheinlich
sein. System Tray. Das hatten wir.
Aber schon. Icons in Bar.
Ich fürchte fast das ist schon
alles was man damit machen kann.
Ich meine es ist wie bei i3.
Bei i3 kannst du ja auch nicht wirklich viel damit
machen. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch der einzige
Grund warum ich i3
mag und alle anderen Sachen auf
dem Linux Desktop eben nicht mag.
Weil i3
ist sehr überschaubar.
Leute ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich kann es nicht unter Windows verwenden.
Weil.
Also ich würde es. Normalerweise würde
ich es mal ausprobieren. So einfach wie sich
es anfühlt mal ein paar Tage das zu benutzen.
Aber ich kann es nicht verwenden.
Weil ich muss auf der Arbeit Windows verwenden.
Und wenn ich mich an die Bedienung
von einem Tiling Window Manager unter Windows gewöhne
dann kann ich mein normales Windows und umgedreht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wo ist jetzt der Vorteil zum normalen Desktop?
Ja das es einfach angenehmer ist
mit der Tastatur
zu bedienen.
Du weißt immer hier hast du deinen Browser.
Hier hast du deinen Terminal. Hier hast du deinen Editor.
Was eigentlich ohne Scheiß
90% der Sachen sind die ich brauche.
Ja.
Unter Windows ist es ehrlich gesagt so
hauptsächlich der Browser.
Man könnte jetzt Steam starten und sowas
hier drauf noch. Aber das
könnte ich dann tatsächlich
auf dem eigenen Desktop oder so.
Ich finde es gar nicht mal so doof.
Wobei man halt auch mal ehrlich sagen muss.
Der Vorteil
versus
also ich habe ja hier eh
ich habe 3 Anwendungen im Fullscreen auf
aktuell ja.
Der Vorteil versus
Windows Desktops ist es eigentlich nicht
wert.
Ja. Ja meine ich.
Aber guck ich kann auch Windows Desktops
wechseln. Und ich habe
hier ne also 1. 1. 2. 3.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so nice
hier wie bei i3 mit dem durchswitchen.
Und wenn man dann doch
mal teilen muss ist es auf jeden Fall
nicht verkehrt.
Aber so wie ich das hier benutzen würde mit 3
Fenstern im Fullscreen
dafür reicht auch die eingebaute
Windows Desktop Switch Funktion.
Gibt das hier. Was ist das?
Como. Como
Ebi. Teile Window Manager
for Windows
PS. Powershell oder was?
Moment ist das ein komplettes
Powershell Ding?
Oh. Leute.
Wisst ihr was ich da sehe?
Was sehe ich
denn da?
Das ist Blazingly Fast.
Die Krustentiere sind am Start.
Blazingly Fast
written in Rust.
Was? Left VM.
Das ist aber nicht für Windows oder?
Das ist für
oder?
Das ist für Linux oder?
Steht da Windows?
Ne ne das ist für Linux hier.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich
so wie ich mir vorstelle Wayland Only.
Ach ne es ist
SSX. Also obsolet.
Naja es funktioniert halt.
Und warum sollte man beispielsweise
das verwenden anstatt das i3?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Weil es Blazingly Fast
written in Rust ist oder wie?
Und das ist Überzeugung.
Das ist quasi überzeugend
genug written in Rust.
Wie war die Tastenkombi bei
Windows für switchen?
Control Windows Taste
und dann Pfeiltaste links rechts.
Why go left?
Ok.
Ok wenn die erste Begründung schon ist
warum man es benutzen soll
weil es ein Tiling
Window Manager written in Rust ist
das wäre für mich
eines der letzten Begründungen überhaupt
in welcher Sprache man Window Manager
ok sagen wir mal so
ähm
wenn es ja war würde ich es wahrscheinlich erst gar nicht
ausprobieren.
Stable and performant.
Ich hatte ehrlich gesagt
also ich glaube i3 hat nicht
bei ihnen auf den Faden stehen Performance.
Ich hatte glaube ich noch nicht
einen Fall das i3
jemals wirklich jemals
gelaggt hat.
i3 macht halt einfach auch nichts
wo es irgendwie laggen könnte.
Es hat keine Animationen
das hat nix i3 kann nix
i3 macht nix deswegen mag ich i3.
Die haben doch bestimmt
irgendwie ne issue
warum man das anstelle von i3 verwenden soll.
Boah Vorfall ist am Start.
Ähm.
Den kenn ich nicht.
Aber der ist written in Rust das ist natürlich
noch viel geiler.
Das probieren wir jetzt auch noch aus.
Komorebi
Also dann beenden wir Glaze mal.
Oh es beendet
und jetzt wie?
Komorebi äh Moment
was war? Komorebi
GitHub
Ach Chat
wirklich ja
X11 geht Black Screen lag
an Wayland.
Was ich schon vermutet habe.
Two types of padding.
Oh hier kriegen wir das gezeigt.
Wir probieren das jetzt selbst aus.
Komorebi
Ne
Was war das andere?
Animated Wallpapers
Vor Linux
Ah ja nice
Outdated Overrated
Projekt
Dann downloaden wir das mal.
MSI
Julius
Ist halb
Leute wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen?
Wisst ihr was wir machen?
Wir kompilieren das unter Windows
from scratch.
Das wird jetzt was.
Build from Source
Ok wie installiert man Rust unter Windows?
Kann das WinGet?
WinGet
Search Rust
RustUp ist der
Version Manager.
Okay
WinGet
WinGet Install
RustUp
Ich find's auch ein bisschen doof
Man weiß nirgendwo wo das herkommt.
Wie wär's mit nem Projektlink?
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal die richtige Stelle.
So jetzt wird
erst mal 3000 Sachen installiert.
So wie das bei Rust üblich ist.
Das in ein Rust Projekt
irgendwie aus 700 Dependency
Cargo Dependencies
Cargo Packages. Komm mal
das probieren.
WinGet Info RustUp
Ne natürlich nicht.
Rust. Okay da muss ich bestimmt neu starten.
Ne das funktioniert.
Rust.
Da ist es doch.
Cargo. Nice. Schon haben wir's
am Start. Jetzt muss ich noch
WinGet Install Shit
Ne haben wir nicht.
Git.Git muss ich installieren.
Git for Windows
Oh ne das ist mit dieser komischen Git Bash
Shell und sowas. Ganz ekliges Zeug.
So Building
Oh ist das etwa ein
Window Manager für Weebs? Habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen?
Naja fast.
Wo ist der Sbarro?
Okay Building from Source wollte ich mir angucken.
Building
Building from Source
You can then clone this repo
and compile the source code to install the
binaries for code.
Okay die zwei Sachen
muss ich machen anscheinend.
Paste. Ach Quatsch. Ich hab's ja immer geklont.
Ja das stimmt.
Download. Clone.
Git. Ja das ist ja Windows ist ja nicht
in der Lage das zu reloaden.
Jetzt. Git. Jawoll.
Git. Clone.
Das Pflaster am
Finger nervt mich.
Ccomogebi
Ne da steht
einfach ich muss
Da steht drinnen ich muss
das Repo klonen.
Ah die readme die macht mich fertig.
Da steht
Ich muss das. Die hab ich.
Die hab ich doch.
Und jetzt machen wir einfach sowas
hier. Dann sollte es
gehen. Was macht
Minus Minus Locked?
Doch doch. Also Rust ist nicht ganz so schlimm
wie Node.js aber ihr seht es ja hier.
Moment was brauche ich
alles?
Link Exe not found.
Ah ja.
Build Tools muss ich installieren.
I download
Build Tools von Microsoft Visual Studio.
Ok.
Was auch immer ich da gerade installiere.
Eigentlich
will ich nur die Build Tools installieren.
Oh Peter
von Microsoft Support.
Microsoft Gold
Partner Support.
Äh.
Einfach sagen install
jetzt. Übrigens an diesem
UI Installer seht ihr das Microsoft ihre
eigene UI Technologie nicht verwendet. Ich glaube
der ist nämlich in Elektron der Installer
oder? Lounge was passiert?
Wenn ich Build Tools launche.
Ok es geht ne Shell auf.
Na toll.
Da wären wir nie drauf gekommen.
Äh. Ok das hat bestimmt
wieder nicht geladen. Link.
Ne.
Das geht nicht.
Muss ich das hier drüber starten?
Link Punkt Exe.
Ne.
Oh Moment.
Build Tools for Visual
Install with Visual C++
Option. Hab ich das
gemacht?
Modify. Muss ich das
da machen?
Wow. Alter.
Was legt denn der da alles runter?
Und
und was? Und was muss ich?
Hier. Build Tools.
Alter Windows
das ist doch alles. Man kann jetzt übrigens
doch nicht mal hier neben ausklappen.
Das auch?
Ne PowerShell neu starten hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich hab ja sogar die Build Tools
gestartet aber das gibts da nicht.
Guck.
Reicht das wenn ich
so installiere? Einfach so?
Also das reicht so.
Modify. Jetzt muss der
einfach mal 6 GB
runterladen.
Du kannst das separat...
Also ich weiß schon warum ich
seit Jahren nichts mehr unter Windows
entwickle.
Ok es ist C. Also es ist
C++. C++ ist pauschal eh immer
Kacke.
Ich bemitleide alle Unreal Entwickler.
Wobei ich glaub
Unreal verwendet
einfach den ganzen
C++ Bullshit nicht und
hat viel eigenes drum herum gestrickt.
Wir bauen überhaupt
nicht den FIA Champ neu. Heute hat
schlicht und ergreifend niemand angepasst.
Ist meine Zeitzone falsch?
Kann das sein?
Ich glaube wir haben nämlich
21.33 Uhr
Chatgear. Oder?
Ich muss aufs Handy gucken.
Ja.
21.33 Uhr
Was macht der da eigentlich gerade?
Ah der ist fertig
mit Downloaden. Der installiert jetzt.
Moment was?
Installing Package 105
auf 271
Alter.
Ok wie macht man denn die Zeitzone
hier richtig?
Gucken ob ich das wenigstens finde.
Adjust Date and Time.
Time Zone. Ok.
Amsterdam Berlin.
Ok wenigstens funktioniert sowas unter Windows
halbwegs brauchbar.
Was macht der da eigentlich gerade?
Ist der immer noch am installieren?
Oh der installiert das Windows 10 SDK.
Das ist bestimmt ein bisschen größer.
Mal kurz in Task Manager gucken was
der da treibt.
Windows Update?
Ich checke nie was da im Hintergrund passiert.
Wisst ihr das mag ich unter
Linux auch. Da machst du
Top oder Htop oder Btop
oder Bdingsbums. Eines der
15.000
Top Klone auf
und siehst welcher Prozess
da was macht. Du siehst mit
welchen Parametern der gestartet
wurde. Du kannst dir auch
meistens was darunter vorstellen.
Ja unter Windows brauchst du Zusatzdinger.
Und selbst im Prozessexplorer
weißt du oftmals nicht was es ist.
Weil guck mal ernsthaft.
Du guckst hier bei Windows rein ja
und du siehst dann so Dinger wie
wobei wir waren ja
Prozessexplorer
laden wir mal runter. Download.
herunterladen
Prozessexplorer
Run
aggregl
So sortieren wir mal
nach cpu last.
Also erstens guck mal
wie viel krasses Zeug da schon läuft
So und dann hast du so Dinger
du weißt halt einfach immer nicht
was es ist unter Windows.
Smart Screen mit einem
Antivirus da hast du Dinger wie
Der TI-Worker-Exe, ja, oh Gott, nice, alles klar
VG-Auth-Server, okay, das ist vor allem, ja
Trusted-Installer
Ganz viel SV-Host-Exe
SI-Host
Security und Health-Sys-Tray
Wisst ihr, du hast unter Windows, ja, dreimal Runtime-Broker
Du hast unter Windows so viel Zeug, denn NIST-Server
Standardmäßig laufen, was du nicht installiert hast, du
Hier, CHX-Smart-Skript, da tauchen auch immer mal wieder neue Dinger drin auf
Der Aggregator-Host, du hast keine Ahnung, was es ist
Alles jetzt geschafft, oh, er ist fertig
Pogu
Okay, und jetzt? Link
Hey
Okay, da drin funktioniert das, nice
Okay, CD
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das wechselt
CD, Users, CD
Äh
Keg
CD
Äh, wie heißt das Ordner, den ich geklont hab?
Hier, Komoremi
Und jetzt Cargo
Achso, Reverse Search geht ja nicht
Shell History geht natürlich auch nicht
Geil
Windows ist so eine Krücke, was das angeht, Alter
Oh, es funktioniert, Leute
Es geht
Es compiled jetzt erstmal drei Stunden
Weil es 185 Dependencies
Vom Scratch
Compilen muss
Glücklicherweise ist Rust ganz gut drinne
Abhängigkeiten zu erkennen
Und parallel zu kompilieren, wie man hier sieht, ganz gut
Übrigens auch so ein Ding, ne
Wo man sich fragt, warum kriegen die das bei C++ nicht hin
So ein ordentliches Command-Line-Build-Dings da gleich mitzuliefern
Oder zumindest
Was in der Richtung
Wo man dann zum Beispiel auch Packages installieren kann
Und keine Packages installieren kann
Und keine Header-Files man rumkopieren muss
Ja, bis Make funktioniert
Und das alles baut, was du willst
Nachdem du dir zig Header-Files angeguckt hast auf GitHub
Header-Files sind quasi das
Was in anderen Sprachen
Metainformationen sind
Also in anderen Sprachen hast du oft so Metainformationen
Welche Funktionen es gibt und sowas
Hast du irgendwie Binary gebundelt
Mit der Library
Bei C++ nicht
Und dann hast du auch so ein paar
Bei C++ brauchst du dafür Header-Files
Dass du zum Beispiel weißt, dass es eine Funktion gibt, die
Show
So, hat funktioniert, Leute
Wir haben
Compiled
Und jetzt noch
Oh, das geht schneller
Das flutscht
Oh ne, jetzt sind es ja nur 192 Packages
Sowas wie ein Interface
Ja
Naja
Man kann es nicht mit einem C-Sharp-Interface machen
Man kann es mit einem C-Sharp-Interface vergleichen
Das eine ist so quasi ein Language-Konstrukt
Und das andere
Metainfos zu wie man was aufrufen kann
Aber ja, ein bisschen wie ein Interface
Aber dann müssen die Variablen
Die Funktion nimmt auch im Header-File stehen
Richtig, ja
Ist ja auch so
Es heißt nicht Variablen, es heißt dann da Parameter
Aber ja, ist so
Ja, super ausgereifte Packages
Alle
So, und jetzt, wie startet man das dann?
Oh, grad
Dabei sind
Äh, was machen die da?
It is highly recommended to enable support for long paths in Windows
Was?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Was soll long paths sein?
Ich dachte, Windows hat schon seit Ewigkeiten keine Beschränkungen mehr
Wie lang Dateinamen und sowas sein dürfen
Wie, die
Ernsthaft, da gibt es doch eine Beschränkung?
Alter, das System ist einfach so krass
PP-Gas-Shit
Der Wahnsinn
Und jetzt sage ich, dass ich das nicht mehr kann
Ich komme, Rebis start
Minus WHKD
Ja, obviously, WHKD
Natürlich, was sonst?
Ist ja klar, man
Could not find WHKD
Ja, was ist denn WHKD überhaupt, man?
Moment, was?
Komoribe does not handle any keyboard or mouse inputs?
Wie soll denn Windows Manager funktionieren ohne...
Okay, WHKD muss ich installieren
Ich weiß, wusste bisher nicht mal, dass es das überhaupt gibt, man
WKHD halt, easy
Okay, wir installieren WKHD
Klar
Hat es jetzt funktioniert?
Das findet er jetzt wieder nicht
Weil...
PowerShell
Kann es sein, dass es überhaupt nicht installiert ist?
Dass es einfach jebaited?
Ey, Windows
Das ist so schrottig alles
So, jetzt habe ich WKHD installiert
Und weiter?
Geht immer noch nicht
Warum trägt sich das nicht selbst in Paths ein?
Ich meine, wir können es scheiß auf selbst kompilieren
Ihr habt noch irgendeinen Quickstart, oder?
Quickstart
Ja, habe ich, habe ich
Das habe ich doch installiert hier
Paths neu lernen, habe ich gemacht
Findet er nicht
Oh
Auf einmal doch
Wie oft muss ich das noch neu starten?
Could not find file
Was ist IWR?
Ja
Okay, IWR wurde ausgeführt
Was?
Invoke Web Request
Das ist gerade die PowerShell-Curl, oder wie?
Oh, macht er was?
Macht er was?
Was?
Ich glaube, das ist kaputt
Kann es sein, dass das crasht, oder so?
Ne, habe ich nicht
Du hast recht
Fetch?
Das ist echt
Für absolute High IQ, Leute
Okay, was auch immer
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay
ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen hakelig unter windows aber ich war ein cool dass es die leute
probieren aber ich glaube irgendwie so wirklich usable ist das alles nicht ja ja ich sitze immer
noch am window tiling manager scheint jetzt auch zu funktionieren der zweite den wir ausprobiert
haben die gingen die gingen ja beide also ging also ja also sie machen das was sie sollen wie
schaltet man das aus wahrscheinlich einfach das terminal schließen dem ans gestartet hat
glaube ich eine exzellente frage wie man das ausschaltet das läuft doch hier bestimmt oder
homo komori wie einfach aus einfach abschießen beim als ich aus als ich aus komori bietet jetzt
war aber blöde frau was ist wie hkd github es simple hotkey die man für windows
also sowas wie auto id oder so oder auto hotkey oder also windows version von skh kd habe ich auch
nie verwendet in rust ja dann ist natürlich alles gut wenn das in rust ist weil in rust ist es playsichtlich fast
wie wir alle wissen chat wird eigentlich mal zeit dass wir auch im stream mehr rust programmieren
oder dass die ganzen krustentiere sich freuen
da kriegt das halte ich nicht aus das halte ich nicht aus zu viel was so ein bisschen was geht aber
zu viel was ist echt nix da wirst du verrückt im kopf der chat im rast leute ich krieg vier chat
noch nicht meiner sprache zustande die ich gescheit kann dann wird das in rast garantiert auch nichts
werden also manche sie ist tatsächlich sogar noch angenehmer besteht zumindest glücklicherweise nicht
aus tausend dollar zeichen wie rast was ist fiat champ ein
home assistant plugin was ich gebaut habe mit dem man daten von seinem elektroauto abfragen kann
guck hier fiat champ es hat absolut keine bugs wie du daran siehst dass es 28 issues gibt um die ich
mich nicht kümmere weil ich zu faul bin und keinen bock hab da kannst du für home assistant kannst
den home assistant sachen über dein elektroauto abfragen letztes commit von im jahr 15 dezember
nice
das ist super einfach von richtig Hai
das ist super einfach hiding
a
so
dann
als
es funktioniert auch gut es funktioniert es hat halt ein paar
Sp Proteische
so dass man nur ein auto trainer einfügen kann und nicht zwei also wenn
wenn beispielsweise
einer ein
ob und 1 4 hat dann funktioniert das nicht
2 4
Ich wollte dem Ding ja auch mal ein Web-Interface spendieren,
dass man es ordentlich konfigurieren kann.
Außerhalb von diesem
Homosystem-Config-Dialog.
Ich bin so faul.
Ich habe so wenig Bock, gerade da dran
weiterzumachen.
Warum nicht? Wir haben sogar teilweise schon im Stream
gebaut. Aber ich habe einfach keinen Bock
gerade dran weiterzubauen. Das liegt vielleicht
einfach daran, dass es funktioniert für mich
und es macht, was es soll und deswegen
ich keine
große Motivation verspüre, da
weiter dran zu bauen.
Einen neuen Maintainer hinzufügen.
Niemand möchte sowas maintainen.
Doch, habe ich. Ich wollte das
Weltweb-UI bauen.
4M-Champ ist finaler. Kommt da nichts mehr
außer... 4M-Champ
kommt
erst wieder was, wenn ich es verwende
und feststelle, ich brauche was.
Also, weiß ich nicht.
Was ich da... Ich bin super
unmotiviert, an Sachen weiterzubauen,
mich zu motivieren, an Sachen
weiterzubauen
oder Sachen zu
supporten, auf die ich gerade keinen Bock habe.
Wobei 4M-Champ
echt mega nice
4M-Champ ist.
Ja, 4M-Champ.
Was ist das? Permission? Neues.
Neues.
Hm.
Der ist aus dem Stream, oder?
Ich glaube, ich setze
alle meine
Projekte auf Archiv, dann...
Dann muss ich...
Dann muss ich wenigstens kein schlechtes Gewissen mehr haben,
da ich den Leuten immer nicht antworte.
Es gibt einen Rustfork, ja.
Ich habe aber, ehrlich gesagt, bis heute
nicht genau verstanden,
warum es das gibt
und ob sich da überhaupt was tut.
Da tut sich ja eigentlich gar nichts, ne?
Hat 5000 Dings
vor einem Monat das letzte Mal committed.
Also,
im Prinzip ist das unsinnig, so.
Das updatet einfach auch einfach
niemand.
Also, richtig, richtig unsinniger,
unsinniger Fork.
Ja, ist schön, dass sie es geforkt haben,
aber wenn sie noch nicht mal
Upstream reinmerchen, dann...
Also, keine Ahnung, was der Sinn davon ist.
Aber Hauptsache ein Twitter-Account,
Grappling.
Ja, lass Rust forken.
Free... Genau, genau.
Wir forken Rust, greifen Free-Sterne
ab auf GitHub und dann überschreiben
wir das Repo mit irgendwas anderem.
Und dann
sellen wir es auf Ebay.
Wobei, sowas sellt man nicht auf Ebay.
Richtig big stonks.
Um Thema
Stonks. Lass mich grad mal kurz gucken.
Kurz bevor ich ins Bett gehen muss.
Was meine Stonks
denn so machen?
Oh, Stonks sind eigentlich ganz gut
mittlerweile wieder.
Naja.
Stonks sind wieder runtergegangen und jetzt wieder ein bisschen hoch.
Oh, Stonks sind okay.
Was, die Dogecoin-Stonks?
Wirklich?
Warum gehen die mal wieder?
Tatsächlich.
Warum ist Dogecoin
gerade mal wieder angesagt?
Ja, anscheinend schon.
Du hast Glück.
Das stimmt, was du gesagt hast.
Warum genau sind Dogecoin
gerade so Stonks?
Ah, okay. Naja, auf Gesamt betrachtet
nicht.
Was macht eigentlich Bitcoin gerade?
Ja.
Vor einer Woche ist Bitcoin wieder ein bisschen hoch.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Bann. Ja, immer noch.
Incredible Fortunes.
Fast. Ist es denn auch written in Rust, ja?
Ich hoffe mal für die.
Nein, in SICK.
Deswegen ist es Incredible Fast und nicht Blazingly Fast.
SICK haben wir auch schon mal im Stream gemacht.
Hat mir syntaktisch nicht gut gefallen.
Wobei wir auch quasi so eine Mischung aus SICK und C-Interop gemacht haben.
Und das war, die hatten so eine ganz komische Pointer-Syntax bei SICK.
So was war das doch, gell?
Sternchen, Punkt, Sternchen und so ganz weird.
Ja, Chatgear, ich würde sagen, wir machen die Windows-VM mal aus.
Boah, nicht Standby. Standby verbraucht so viel Disk, ja.
Hau auf.
Und ich lasse die mal da, weil man weiß nicht, wann ich wieder eine Windows 11-VM brauche.
Ey, Snapshot müssen wir das nennen. Das ist eh outdated das nächste Mal.
Ich glaube, ich könnte es wahrscheinlich auch wieder löschen.
Weil es ist einfach sinnlos.
Dead Space?
Warum habe ich hier Dead Space?
Nein, gut, man weiß es nicht.
Swift, ja.
Der Bike Champ.
Wo ist denn der Ordner jetzt?
25, GIG.
Ja, VMs runterladen, vielleicht echt die sinnvollere Variante das nächste Mal.
Wobei der Installer war nur wirklich auch schnell durchgeklickt.
Aber das Ganze geupdatet danach.
Das hat schon eine halbe Stunde gedauert insgesamt.
Okay, Leute.
Morgen setze ich mich mal aufs Fahrrad und wir fahren eine Runde im Stream.
Ey.
Brauche ich mal eine Ruhe.
Wenigstens hast du keinen Docker-Desktop auf der Windows-VM gemacht.
Ich wüsste eh nicht, warum ich Docker-Desktop verwenden sollte.
Ja, haben wir.
Wir haben uns das angeschaut noch, ähm, also schon ein bisschen,
ein bisschen bevor das spruchreif war.
Da musste man noch diesen, diesen Copilot,
über Registry-Hacks aktivieren.
Also das Beste, was sie eingeführt haben,
und das gibt's jetzt ja anscheinend auch schon in Windows,
ist diese Geschichte mit, dass man endlich wieder Taskleiste entgroupen kann.
Und zwar super hässlich gemacht,
aber immerhin,
immerhin geht das wieder.
Aber Windows ist halt echt so ein Flickenstückelgestückeldes Werk, äh,
aus unterschiedlichsten Teilen, das ist schon nervig.
Man könnte es einfach auch in was gescheitermachen.
Und selbst da bekomme ich es ja nicht hin, weil ich irgendwie sehr unmotiviert bin, da weiterzumachen.
Ja, warum nicht, wenn es da alles gibt, was du brauchst?
Ich habe ja auch nur die Kombination aus Windows und Linux.
Naja, gut, ihr wisst ja, wie es aussieht normalerweise.
Ich habe ja auch nur die Kombination aus Windows und Linux, weil ich eigentlich so gut wie alles,
was Technik-Sachen angeht, unter Linux mache,
und für Videos, Streaming und für Spielen halt Windows verwende.
Das ist auch das, es ist wie gesagt meiner Meinung nach das Beste, was man machen kann.
Einfach das System benutzen, was halt in dem jeweiligen Sektor, was man machen will, seine Stärken hat.
Und guckt da, Windows, Linux in der VM.
Und Linux in der VM finde ich persönlich immer noch am besten, weil es läuft halt parallel, man kann beides parallel verwenden.
Und es ist schnell genug,
also es gibt nichts, was mich hier in der VM groß stört, performancetechnisch.
Gut, ich meine, die VM ist auch fett bestückt, 24 GB RAM, 8 Cores,
bei Batocera, ne, was soll es da Neues geben?
Es gibt eine neue Version, die müssen wir uns vielleicht mal angucken.
Die kann jetzt ja angeblich auch, glaube ich, Xbox von Haus aus oder Xbox 360 von Haus aus.
Soll aber noch mehr schlecht als recht funktionieren.
Grafik-Memory, weiß nicht, 256.
Ich meine, das ist halt auch das geile, i3 braucht halt nichts und läuft trotzdem schnell.
Ah, 256 oder sowas.
Oh, warum so viel?
Das ist komplett unsinnig.
Warum hat es 8 GB Grafikspeicher?
Das macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Null.
Warum brauche ich 8 GB für i3?
Ja, also das Terminal und i3 zusammen, da sind die 8 GB.
Die Arbeit aber schon ganz kritisch, ja.
Wenn du Linux auf dem Mac laufen lässt, da kannst du auch gleich auf einer normalen Kiste laufen lassen, oder?
Es sei denn, du feierst halt die Hardware, okay.
So, 22.03 Uhr, Leute.
Ihr wisst, was jetzt kommt.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen, ich muss ins Bett.
Ich habe heute, by the way, ein neues Video aufgenommen.
Aber ich muss es noch rendern, hochladen und mir einen Titel aus den Fingern saugen.
Und morgen bin ich in Frankfurt auf der Arbeit.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich am Mittwoch.
Ja, kompletten Dezember wieder frei.
Sogar theoretisch mehr als Dezember, weil ich noch so viele Tage habe über...
Krelaks, danke für den Sub.
Du weißt doch, gerade in Zeiten, wo ich nicht viel hochlade, muss man subscribed bleiben.
Sonst hat man gar keine Chance, es mitzubekommen, wenn was hochgeladen wird.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe sogar schon mal für ein paar Titel Chat-GPT probiert.
Aber da muss man auch ziemlich rumwursten, bis da was Brauchbares ist.
Es ist eher gut für Denkanstöße, nicht wirklich um kompletten Titel zu bauen, finde ich.
Du hast da eine Bewerbung mit Chat-GPT geschrieben.
Ich würde ja sagen, poste mal.
Die können wir uns angucken.
Aber du wirst deine Bewerbung nicht öffentlich im Internet posten wollen.
Würde ich auch nicht machen.
Ich würde mich interessieren, ob da was Gescheites bei rausgekommen ist.
Top-Idee.
Aber...
Falls du mal wieder im Stream da bist, sag Bescheid.
Dann schick mir einfach einen Link hier irgendwie auf Google Drive oder auf irgendwas, wo du willst.
Würde mich echt interessieren, was da rausgekommen ist.
Oder kannst du auch Copy-Pasten und auf Pastebin hauen oder so.
Geht mir eher um den Text, den Chat-GPT generiert hat.
Okay, Chat-G.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
Keck bei.
See you.